à
on faisait ça quand la route des
tamarins était en travaux en fait donc
il y avait personne on venait que les
week-ends pour
même que dimanche pour éviter toute gêne
à food rencontre malencontreuse gros
camions ou autre à l'époque c'était
fermé
très content et leur pénible ceci dit
c'est un bon ride c'est pas trois quatre
minutes ah ouais on s'éclate et bien on
suivait tous l'itinéraire ça partait
d'ici de l'éperon jusqu'à
proviennent du à du ca de saint paul ça
fait 3 km 4 de descente et voilà c'était
sympa parce que justement il y avait
personne l'itinéraire était top donc le
bitume était tout neuf donc voilà ça
glissait bien de quoi se mettre des
bonnes boîtes et bonnes sensations
aucune route qui est large déjà donc ça
nous permet de slide et pour plus de
sensations pour pouvoir freiner un petit
peu aussi
et une bonne descente pas des virages à
90 degrés
donc des sensations de vitesse qui
montrent beaucoup plus vite sensation
car oui
des bons virages on peut bien
s'accroupir sur la planche ou bien
appuyé dessus bien repartir dans le sens
pouvoir après se taper un shoot par
exemple
en partant d'ici la descente qui est
légère et plus on arrive vers saint paul
puis ça s'accentue et donc la vitesse
commencé à bien s'accélérer donc être
plus souple pas comme moi
question gamelle on en a pris certes
notamment une deux ans dans la petite
vidéo on n'a pas de casque on n'a pas de
protection c'est pas du tout à faire moi
suisse à ça je me suis acheté un casque
et des protections et ce que je pensais
sur les remontées puisque on faisait les
remonter à pied on à moi j'ai eu quand
même le temps d'apprécier les paysages
dont les baleines c'est ce qu'à la
saison des bennes c'était génial
brouillons magique du coucher de 200
musulmans et ça devient bien
des petites frayeurs en fait nous en
tant qu'amateur ce qui nous permettait
d'y aller et pas trop se faire mal c'est
surtout la largeur de la route qui en
tant que nous hisser débutants et
amateurs qu'on fait nous permettez en
fait de ralentir c'est le seul moyen
qu'on avait de ralentir
la route fermée l'idéal quand on de
fermer quatre voies pour nous tous seuls
nous on est partant pour une campagne
électorale en construction la qui fait
tout le tour ça nous laisse deux trois
ans pour faire de longboard